[Música]
como está o nome da lei 4 sobre quem
fala daqui são muito bons vinhos mais um
vídeo e hoje nós vamos fazer pessoal
como eu estava com meu amigo
2 o que espero que não tenha ouvido isto
pessoal time que muitas coisas precisam
então perdeu um espírito muito mais por
que subscreveu para lançar o vídeo foi
eu fui eu não fui eu
olha que foi saber que pude ajudar o
amigo dói para fazer essa porcaria papa
escolhidas e nem da asp para comprar uma
câmera para gravar eu queria
[Música]
não há qualquer coisa se passou no
quarto sobre você não conseguir ser
convocado
[Risadas]
[Música]
descobri isso aqui não tem piada nenhuma
nós agora cinco anos acompanhou a
corporação inclusive colo jogam já chega
a 55 anos foi encontrada aqui palavras
em destaque dentro de seu corpo de
guardas 50 euros a quem mais puder daria
só vem atuando num erro de palavras em
torno de 50 euros
eu não
[Música]
eu não quero sair do ônibus e não vou
fazer porque ele perdeu aqui ou ligue
para o número 10 que foi mais um erro da
spu lidam abin
com isso o barulho para fora
para anthony para com isso
então está tudo bem bom dia como estava
o amigo 2
[Música]